the legal battle between kesha's family
and former producer dr. Luke continues
dr. Luke has filed a new lawsuit against
the tic toc singers mom Phoebe sebert
according to court docs obtained by et
the libel lawsuit filed in Tennessee
Wednesday alleges kesha's mother
continued to publicly defame him this is
dr. Luke second time suing sebert for
defamation he previously filed a
complaint in October 2014 dr. Luke's
lawyers told ET after we originally
filed suit against Phoebe severed she
continued to make outrageous false and
defamatory statements against dr. Luke
in her widespread media campaign to
damage and smear his name separates
attorney also shared in the statement
quote mrs. Seibert looks forward to
presenting her case to a jury as soon as
possible when the evidence is made
public she expects a jury will conclude
that all of her statements have been
justified as ET previously reported
Kesha dismissed her sexual assault
lawsuit against dr. Luke to focus on
making new music you break me down